so und dann schlägt natürlich gerade die
große stunde der lobbyisten
wen wundert's bei der vielen starts
kohle die wegen corona verballert wird
sind die kollegen quasi im blutrausch
wie immer ganz vorne mit dabei die
autoindustrie vw zum beispiel schlägt
jetzt die nächste abwrackprämie vor
ja also noch eine staatliche kaufprämie
für neuwagen und zwar auch für
verbrenner sagt vor wie die großen
deutschen automarken sind eben nicht zu
stolz hilfe anzunehmen insbesondere beim
kurzarbeitergeld daimler sparte in der
krise so dank staatlicher unterstützung
einen millionenschweren anteil seiner
personalkosten und obwohl das
unternehmen staatshilfe erhält wollen
die stuttgarter auch in diesem jahr ihre
aktionäre am gewinn aus 2009 10
beteiligen
insgesamt schüttet daimler rund eine
milliarde euro aus auch voll nett mein
tipp an alle kurzarbeiter die ihr sauer
sind kauft euch doch einfach aktien ja
unser problem ist übrigens gar nicht
lobbyismus an sich sondern dass einige
so viel erfolgreicher mobilen als andere
ist einige so viel besser vernetzt sind
sagen wir mal für autobauer oder
hoteliers haben politiker immer ein
offenes ohr in der krise
dafür wird die x-mal versprochene
grundrente seit 2009 übrigens
versprochen schon wieder ausgebremst
unlustiger van fängt am rande allein
50.000 verkäufer im einzelhandel corona
helden und heldinnen müssen auf stocken
und würden sich da über grundrente
später sehr freuen
pech gehabt oder gucken sie sich mal den
sogenannten corona expertenrat von armin
laschet an
an sich eine gute idee doch der verein
lobbycontrol hätte zusammensetzung für
einseitig die unternehmerseite ist sehr
stark vertreten und dominiert fast
dieses gremium könnte man sagen
während es keinerlei
arbeitnehmervertretung gibt die ja aber
dafür gibt es auch kein vertreter der
umweltverbände
das gleicht sich wieder aus deutschland
hat leider immer noch kein verbindliches
lobby-register wo die lobbyisten
reinschreiben müssten mit welchem
politiker sie zu welchem thema reden
aber nicht
und das beste beispiel für wirklich
astreine lobbyarbeit ist aktuell
natürlich unsere bundesliga die ist
offensichtlich
irgendwie schafft ihre geisterspiele
durchzudrücken ist ja so eishockey
handball alle mussten die spielzeiten
beenden die nicht systemrelevantes opium
fürs volk kein mallorca und kein fußball
das geht offenbar nicht
wir schauen mal live zu holger stockhaus
aus der pr-abteilung der deutschen
fußball liga dfl
herr stock aus warum sind sie denn heute
schon im stadion weil ich auf entzug bin
herr welke weil ich es einfach brauche
diesen hexenkessel stadion auch ohne
fans in seine entschuldigung und das
sage ich jetzt ausdrücklich in meiner
eigenschaft als arbeitsloser
sportmoderator fußball lebt doch von der
interaktion mit dem zuschauer ehrlich
ohne live publikum ist das tot so was
wird doch keine sau sehen
ernsthaft im publikum und was macht sie
so sicher dass geisterspiele kommen das
entscheidet die politik doch erst in den
nächsten wochen ja ja aber wir haben ja
schon gesagt was sie entscheiden
außerdem stand in der bild letzten
dienstag ganzseitige anzeige von sky ich
lese mal vor die bundesliga ist bald
wieder da ja
[Musik]
sky passt seine texte immer an das
sprachliche niveau von fußballfans an
natürlich kommen geisterspiele und mein
chef sagt klipp und klar auch für uns
gilt wie für alle anderen und das ist ja
auch völlig nachvollziehbar und auch gar
nicht anders zu erwarten das erwartet
auch niemand von uns das ist hier keine
extrawürste für die für die bundesliga
gibt
ich möchte das noch mal ausdrücklich
wiederholen es erwartet niemand dass es
hier keine extrawürste für die
bundesliga gibt er hat also nicht
gelogen ja für euer sogar eines hygiene
konzept braucht ihr nur für diese saison
20 bis 30.000 corona tests selbst wenn
ihr die in privaten labors kauft könnten
ja trotzdem woanders fehlen wenn eine
zweite große welle kommt was wenn dann
tests für altenpfleger fehlen ja
natürlich da kommt da wieder mit der
pflege gucken wir doch zur abwechslung
mal auf die fakten
das ist bgb altenpflegerin aus
ibbenbüren so und das hier ist srey vom
fc bayern
er hat bis heute elf saisontore erzielt
sie neu
sorry so ist die datenlage ja aber wer
ist ein relevanter für die gesellschaft
gut gucken wir auf die zweikampfwerte
gläubige sind über die hälfte seiner
duelle peggy kein einziges ja ich habe
es verstanden penny ist eine niete wir
versuchen kindern beizubringen dass sie
abstand halten sollen und ihre last
schwitzende männer in kurzen hosen auf
einander los erwäge sagen wenn man so
wende impfstoff wirklich erst nächstes
jahr kommt muss fußball natürlich ein
körperloser sport werden wir haben auch
schon verschiedene ideen
es gibt erste experimente mit
schutzanzügen wir testen ob sich die
spieler mit ein meter fünfzig langen
zollstöcken auf abstand halten können
und warum immer gleich ins tackling
gehen wenn man neben gegner auch ins
knie schießen kann jetzt überzeugt der
welke absolut holger stockhaus holger
stockhaus so krone hat übrigens noch
eine eher harmlose nebenwirkung wegen
der lockdown wochen haben viele deutsche
wollen wahnsinnig zugenommen man lässt
sich halt gehen aber das kann so nicht
bleiben herzlich willkommen zu corona
robic fit durch den sommer mit coach
abdel die soest hallo hier weist mit
quallen zu hause nach spannt die hose
wegen kroner lockdown locker bleiben dir
jetzt voll im plan als im ghetto regel
du musst immer erst fett werden
danach macht training überhaupt erst
sinn fettzellen werden dann in
muskelzellen umgewandelt das nennen wir
definieren und ganz wichtig nur reden
hilft nicht ihr müsst durchziehen
ich bin zum beispiel seit 2003 sah in
dem fitnessstudio angemeldet
ich weiß viele knicken ein und melden
sich habe ich ziehe das durch kaka und
heute zeige ich euch mal ganz spezielle
corona fitness tricks wenn ihr zum
beispiel erfahren dass ihr euren summen
doch noch bis zum sommer selber in mathe
unterrichten ist geht es eigentlich nur
noch um eine sache frustabbau und dabei
hilft diese übung schutzmaske verreisen
zerreißen und auch mal die seite
wechseln
[Musik]
geil
das hat gut getan und wenn dann auch ein
vetter körper braucht einen gesunden
geist hört auf euch den ganzen tag über
kroner meldungen aufzuregen regt euch
lieber über die anderen meldungen auf
die keiner mitkriegt wegen gruner hier
zum beispiel hkk mit annegret hat
möglicherweise aus versehen 45 f 18
kampfjets gekauft beim amerikaner
das war so klar kaum haben die läden
wieder auf rennen die frauen in die
stadt und kaufen irgendeinen schrott
oder hier die rheinbrücke bei leverkusen
als baustelle mittlerweile
weltkulturerbe sollte schon 2025 fertig
werden aber die affäre um den china
stahl könnte dafür sorgen dass sich der
bau der neuen leverkusener brücke um
weitere jahre verzögert andererseits
fischer nach leverkusen
und hier kommt die schönste krone feier
meldung der woche grünes licht für den
br
der tüv hat den neuen flughafen in
berlin genehmigt damit soll der
drittgrößte flughafen deutschlands im
oktober tatsächlich öffnen
der br kommt mit neun jahren verspätung
und genau wenn er fertig ist fliegt
weltweit kein flugzeug mehr
das ist mein humor so letzte übung für
heute erfährt dass ihr euren sohn auch
noch in deutsch bis zum sommer
unterrichten müssen und wir haben das
deutsche mythen vom süden von verbrühten
von gott und wieder in die seite wir
drehen die seiten von kopf und wir
drehen uns in die andere richtung
corona robic fit durch den sommer mit
coach abdel die soest
[Musik]
was denn die über meinen arsch
geigensolo war doch versprochen
ihr könnt ja in der zeit den kanal
abonnieren
[Musik]